purpose of gotaku is to preserve the
story we have this modern convenience of
the camera but when i look at yotaku
image
i feel
more attachment to the experience i got
to live through
[Music]
my name is naoki hayashi i'm a gyotaku
artist gyotaku is a practice of
printing fish in order to document the
lucky outing gyotaku started about 200
years ago in a fishing village in the
southern part of japan
camera wasn't invented yet so people had
to come up with this method to actually
print the actual cats before they ate it
most otaku artists i know they're in
japan but i'm in hawaii i do hawaii
hawaiian gyotaku
[Music]
hawaii we are surrounded by beautiful
nature and the ocean i grew up diving
and fishing one of my grandfather's
friend knew about gyotaku and then so he
got to share that with me every time i
caught something i was able to use the
method to capture the story
[Music]
there's so many different ways of making
yotaku but my way is real simple we
actually go out and catch fish that's
the hardest part and we bring them back
we put non-toxic water-based paint so we
can wash them up and eat later
and then we press paper over it
next we take it to my coloring station
when i add color all the textures and
the movement life comes out so when you
look at them in a frame the fish should
be swimming rather than just stagnant
which isn't good enough to me
i probably print about a thousand fish a
year
my gyotaku when i make it available in
galleries is anywhere from 100 to 20
000.
quite often i get requests by family
they bring in their personal catch
what i enjoy the most is making yotaku
of let's say a family's child's first
catch only happens once in a lifetime
when i make yotaku one of the most
important part is to be able to enjoy
the subject reprinting we should be able
to eat the fish and enjoy it to the
fullest extent
i have passion for fishing i have
passion for nature i learned at younger
age about how beautiful it is our
surroundings
i get energies from the nature and put
them on paper and i share with the world
and that's what i do
[Music]
you